Just as al-Qaeda and its allies are constantly evolving...
...and adapting their efforts to strike us,...
...we have to constantly adapt and evolve to defeat them.
Because as we saw on Christmas, the margin for error is slim...
...and the consequences of failure can be catastrophic.
As these violent extremists pursue new havens,...
...we intend to target al-Qaeda wherever they take root,...
...forging new partnerships to deny them sanctuary...
...as we are doing currently with the government in Yemen.
As our adversaries seek new recruits,...
...we'll constantly review and rapidly update our intelligence and our institutions.
As they refine our tactics, we'll enhance our defenses,...
...including smarter screening and security at airports...
...and investing in the technologies that might have detected the kind of explosives used on Christmas.
In short, we need our intelligence, homeland security and law enforcement systems...
...and the people in them to be accountable, and to work as intended.
Collecting, sharing, integrating, analyzing and acting on intelligence as quickly,...
...and effectively as possible to save innocent lives,...
...not just most of the time, but all of the time.
That's what the American people deserve.
As president, that's exactly what I will demand.
Thank you very much.